[Music]
Fox News Alert new report suggesting the
Tennessee gunman born in Kuwait raised
in Jordan may have traveled back to the
Middle East in the last couple of years
this morning the focus of the
investigation turns to whether he had
ties to any specific terror group Robert
Spencer is the director of
jihadwatch.org he joins us today Robert
was this guy on a Jihad
oh I don't think there's any doubt about
that whatsoever look the Islamic State
made a call to people in the west to
attack military personnel that's exactly
what he did they make a call to Devout
Muslims on the basis of Islamic
principles and on the basis of
grievances where they say look the
infidels have done this so to us they've
done that to us we have to strike back
and this is a man who put a grievance in
his high school yearbook that's the
place where he's supposed to sum up who
he is and what he's all about and he
puts a complaint and it's exactly the
kind of complaint that the Islamic state
uses to try to exhort devout Muslims as
all his friends say abdulaziz was to
commit Jihad attacks okay in his
yearbook he put this up my name causes
National Security alerts what does yours
do also three days before he apparently
murdered these marines in Tennessee
yesterday he updated his blog post and
he wrote This Robert brothers and
sisters don't be fooled by your desires
this life is short and bitter and the
opportunity to submit to Allah may pass
you by now I look at that I don't know
exactly what that means you look at this
you study this what does it mean to you
it sounds to me exactly like the appeals
that the Islamic state has issued to
Muslims to attack G to attack military
personnel police and civilians in the
west it's exactly the same kind of
language that exactly the same kind of
loyalties to the religion that they try
to play upon and say this is your
religious duty this is what you have to
do to please Allah and this is the only
way as a matter of fact that you will
end up being admitted into paradise and
so it's it's not language that's just
pietistic it's designed to lead to
action into exactly the kind of action
that Muhammad Yusuf abdulaziz took
Robert you know the administration and
law enforcement now saying this guy if
he was a terrorist he was never on their
radar but isn't that how Isis is
operating these days you know they find
somebody who's got a clean record and
then they radicalize them through
Twitter and Facebook and everything else
yeah absolutely look they have a whole
manual called how to survive in the west
and it says uh try to blend in as much
as possible don't appear to be overtly
Muslim don't carry around the Quran
don't have a long beard don't wear a
caftan wear western dress don't give
anybody any indication that you might be
somebody who would do something like
this and we see it again and again after
these attacks that all the friends say
well this is the last guy I would have
thought would have done something like
this that's exactly what Isis wants and
that is exactly what this guy's
neighbors told us live on this program
in an hour ago Robert Spencer the
director of
jihadwatch.org sir thank you very much
thank you all right